uh what's your evidence what's the
evidence you've got of what's going on
you have a look at my screen if you
could you'd see that there was more and
more
cases of copied 19 occurring um there's
clearly
still anxiety about covert 19 in the
community where i work in berkshire
i i struggle to understand the
rush towards this so-called freedom day
on the 19th
when we know cases are increasing as
they have done previously
we know when this happens that this
government has formed for making
decisions
too late after the cases increase this
time round they seem to be accelerating
the case increase and relying upon
the fact that we've made some advances
in treatment and on the vaccine rollout
it strikes me as pretty irresponsible
and i struggle to find any
medical professional who's happy about
the management that's being considered
and indeed implemented by this
government i presume the government will
argue
it's already put off this so-called
freedom day for four weeks
there's never a good time to lift
restrictions
um yeah i i heard that said i think it
was by lucy frazier that you know that
somehow if not now
when i mean please everybody just needs
to grow up in government and recognize
that this is a serious pandemic
understand that infectious disease is
actually quite simple
it's about preventing transmission are
you keeping people who have got covert
19 away from others and everything this
government has done in the last 18
months has made this
worse is increased transmission and
indeed
increased the risk of mutation and what
really does concern me is if you're
going to go down this herd immunity
group which they seemingly are doing
belatedly
you are in danger of creating a mutation
that is resistant to the vaccine
and then you've got to tell the public
we're going back in down into another
lockdown in the autumn winter
which i quite understand people don't
want to do but what are we saying that
there are so many deaths worth expending
in order to retain our so-called
freedoms
i don't want to live in a society that
values life so cheaply
when chris whitty talks about as not
being out of the woods bit of an
understatement is it
well i sort of questioned chrissy's
approach and all of this
i only on a separate issue i had to i
left government because
my principles and my professionalism was
basically questioned
by what the government was doing at that
time i couldn't
support something that i knew to be
harmful for the future of my country
i do want to ask the chief medical
officer the question that when he reads
his general medical council guidance
on the practice of a good doctor i.e do
harm do no harm to others
how he can stand next to somebody and
advocate a
policy of opening up um britain at the
moment
at a time when we have not got this uh
virus under control
we do not have enough of an uptake of
the vaccine
double jabbed in the population and we
know that there are mutations
occurring here and elsewhere around the
world that may very well endanger the
effectiveness of these vaccines
i i sort of question whether chris
whitty should really be associating
himself with this in any way whatsoever
and it's not enough
to keep issuing press releases or
comments saying or it might get a bit
difficult in the future to try to absorb
one someone from responsibility if you
are in government
be it as a civil servant or as a
politician
you are ultimately responsible for this
policy of opening up prematurely
without proper controls in place though
on these comments talking about uh could
reach quite scary levels within weeks
and not out of the woods isn't that
distancing himself from what the prime
minister had to say
boris johnson yesterday in fact saying
it was highly probable the worst of the
pacific was over
just me in politics i've heard the line
oh i'm staying on board the ship to try
to make it a more moderate policy it's
better that i stay within the tent
because you know i'm worried about what
would happen if i resigned
it's absolute bs ultimately in life
you have to draw the line and you have
to say i'm sorry i am not supporting
this and i am resigning
and i i think we're reaching the point
where anybody with a medical
qualification or indeed
any qualification that's uh relative
relative um
that is relevant in a pandemic needs to
ask themselves the question
why other countries around the world are
looking on at britain's
essentially experiment and wondering
what on earth we are doing
and i and i personally i i couldn't do
it i could not be standing there and
supporting this policy
i recognize people are fed up i
recognize people want to get back to
normal
we all do we all want to do that but it
must be
the most the right thing to do to be
cautious because i don't want to see
people coming through this surgery or
indeed any other surgeon in the country
who've got long covert
which we're seeing much much more of or
indeed in the worst case examples going
in and we're seeing we're hearing about
young people going in now
to hospital properly sick properly
unwell this is not the flu
i don't want to see that just because we
have a government that seems to want to
just
play games with a virus it doesn't
understand and it has never had the
control of well if chris whiskey wants
to come onto the program he's very
welcome one question are you going to be
wearing your
i'd be very happy to see him interviewed
to be honest with you because i can't
understand
his approach indeed well one question
come monday will you be wearing masks
yes yes i mean i i think in in closed
places wear masks
everyone the thing is is that we can
have some semblance of normality we can
go on holidays we but
but we need to recognize that the close
concentration of people like we saw
outside wembley
is going to increase the spread of this
virus we know this
so yes everybody should continue to wear
a mask indoors
everybody should continue to wear masks
on public transport or anywhere where
there is a
concentration of people gathering that
is the only responsible way forward
it's a small price to pay for us to have
some normality back in our lives